[Music]
welcome to earbiscus the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Rhett and I'm linked
this week at the round table of dim
lighting I don't know exactly
I can't predict yeah man how you're
going to react to this we're being
caught off guard
um yeah we're we we decided to submit
ourselves to an experiment today to see
how I guess in a way how well we know
each other how well we can predict how
the other person would react in a given
scenario a scenario that neither one of
us
knows what what it is what any of them
are going to be because we've asked
Jamie our producer meet Jamie
hello everybody our producer this is
Jamie's first time on not a microphone
in general but on the earbiscus
microphone
and so Jamie you took some time to find
scenarios but also invent scenarios that
you thought that we could attempt to
predict the outcome of yes the response
to the response to yeah and I think with
these ones there's a bit of a thinker
but I think that there are fun scenarios
that you guys could definitely immerse
yourself in
it's too early to think no but you do
your best thinking in the morning not
you but just people in general right oh
the afternoon
that's yeah that's true too what do you
think the good thinking happens
like what was your perception of when
the good thinking happens I haven't
thought about it
I mean I got up earlier this morning
because the weather's kind of wild am
Club no
it's it was the 6 a.m Club well I
thought you got up earlier than that I
haven't gotten back into that yet oh
that's still a residual thing from my
shoulder injury I haven't got back to
the 5 20 wake up oh yeah six o'clock is
the earliest I'm a 6 a.m guy right it's
amazing house it's it's the Ripple
effects of my game being thrown off yeah
but I was excited because it was
supposed to be freaking snowing
well I don't know if your wife was at
home yesterday when it did snow because
for like a little bit Jesse guys got it
on some video I haven't watched it yet
this morning the snowflakes were so big
and then this morning I I should she
gets ready to take uh Shepard to school
and I get a text or I'll get a phone
call from her this is I mean she's
already calling me but you know she
misses me already she was still at the
top of the driveway and she said
you think there's ice on my car you
think it's okay to go down the driveway
because we've got a steep driveway and
if there's any ice on the driveway it is
going to become a ski slope
turns out now
she was fine she was fine she was safe
she was calling me just in case it was
the last goodbye I take Jasper for a
walk
and um
uh it was not snowing it was not raining
but then it started raining on the way
back
snow would be crazy
it might happen it might happen
yeah so I got up for that
I woke up multiple times in the night
because I was like a little kid like
ready to see snowman yeah but you can
literally drive like 20 minutes and
probably see like six inches of snow if
you want to I could but I I wanted to
see it at my house that's a rare thing
huh
yeah that would have been I was excited
man it's happened one time in the 12
years that we've been in Los Angeles I
got um that I remember I got both dogs
out of the bed because I was like we're
gonna walk around it's probably gonna
start snowing but and then we're like
okay after after I peed and I turned
around I couldn't find Jade she'd
immediately hidden under the bed she was
like yeah I don't want to go outside I
can sense what's happening I so I like I
reached way in there drug her out and
just threw it back under the covers and
me and Jasper went for the walk in what
ended up being rained so
could you have predicted that that
that's what I would have done I don't
think I would have predicted that you
would have uh awakened
several times
uh to anticipate snow well that's you
got to get on your A-game if you're
gonna do this okay let's hear the first
one
this one is going to be something what
would Rhett do so link you'll be
answering for this one okay because I'm
not Rhett because you are not however in
this first one what would Rhett do if he
woke up one morning and realized that he
was now in Link's body
no
what would what would red do so this it
what is that a Freaky Friday it's a
Freaky Friday but like half of it
because you're technically not Rhett oh
good yeah where am I and it would be
what happened to me it would be a
Wednesday you're like asleep in the back
of the back corner of one of those lobes
in your brain
oh really so he's possessed me yes he's
possessed me and I'm just
I'm nowhere I'm getting the raw into
this deal I can't even tell you about it
I'm everybody thinks that I still exist
but I don't exist because it's you
possessing me
you're formulating what you would do
yeah yeah yeah because I don't want
anything I say in my prediction to you
know I'm going to form I'm going to come
up with my what I would do in general
and then we'll see how well you are how
well you do this
uh okay
um okay
this is
I mean you said wake up in the morning
so yes it starts off really awkward
because you're in the bed with my wife
and she thinks it's me well just you
know I didn't think about that okay
until you just brought it up well I mean
she did Jamie said you wake up in the
morning right yeah
um
so I'm glad you didn't think about that
I mean all I do is get out of bed
but you could have done anything you
want what would you what would you
actually do let's get real about this
um I wonder if you would just be shocked
I think I think I know I wouldn't be
shocked did you did he expect this was
he told the night before this is gonna
happen because that's a shocking thing
to wake up in another man's body trust
me I know
been there before I see I think
yeah let's just assume there's no shock
like you just or you got over it quickly
but but well
you would be pretty damn shocked
I think you would the main thing would
just be feeling the the the parameters
of a six foot person like you haven't
been six foot since you were in third
grade
no probably uh fifth grade
uh fourth grade probably yeah
and it's yeah
I think I think you because I know the
first thing you do is you get up and you
stretch
you you prevent injury by stretching
your your two long body that's not the
first thing I do now it's the second
thing I do now oh really
well I hope it's not Twitter no okay
good you know the first thing I do right
now morning prayers
I get an ice bath man that's the first
thing and then you stretch after I ain't
got no ice bath and I do stretch but I
don't need it as much as you do this is
tough
um I think that I think you would
I think you would still stretch
because I think you would be exploring
your new body it's like what is this
body feels like wow it's a lot more
vibrant and held together and has so
much more potential like I just feel
like it's just brimming with physical
potential what can I do with this body
today
and of course everybody that's an
interesting take I would say
yeah that you would think the first
thing that I would think when I was in
your body is that I was brimming with
physical potential
because that's been demonstrated time
and again on the internet
well yeah that I haven't that I haven't
realized it's like maybe you're thinking
oh I can realize maybe my brain and your
body you'll actually do things well
right
well just realize my my full physical
potential
okay so far you're not right about
anything I think it's something in here
like I just thought it had to do with I
wouldn't stretch the pains in your own
body sometimes like what are you jealous
about that I have that then you could
Now find yourself experiencing firsthand
I think you're focusing a little bit too
much on if I mean I wouldn't stretch
because
it's in my body if I wake up and
something is wildly out of the norm
in my current life
I might skip stretching I mean we're
talking
once every two months being in my body
it falls in the category of wildly out
of normal yeah right and you're going to
take advantage of not having a stretch
because if you run Nish body it ain't
yours
how long is he in the body
just a day oh a whole day though I'm not
going to go through a whole freaking day
of what you would do in my body
um
I think you would go shopping
because you complained so much about not
being able to find things that fit and
you're like why would I be buying every
time you put your body in the future if
I was going to be in it let me rephrase
that I hope you would go shopping
okay it's not I wasn't thinking I would
go I don't you do have a specific thing
that you're looking for that's an answer
and I actually think that you can
surmise this
I think that I think I think you I could
I mean I need a I need some sort of a
hint like what time of day are we still
in my house
are you out and about I'm just saying
that like the main thing not the
specific like what's the first thing I
would do but the main thing that I would
do once I figured out that uh I was
inside your body
um I have a general idea
as to what I would do and it has to do
with what we do
um
so you would you'd come here
and who's in red if I'm not in Red's
body that's the other question who's
piloting Red's body red is kind of like
on an autopilot mode it's so weird
I mean but you didn't take that into
account you would come to work as me and
you would
I guess you would
what what make some tick tocks
dude I don't know give me another hint I
don't want to give up well
yeah you would do good mythical morning
is that what you're talking about
I I think
I would make it into content
is what I was going to say making it a
content and do you know what type of
content well
first of all the killer impression of
you regardless of what we did right so
regardless of uh blow people's mouth
what I did when I was in your body
everyone would just interpret it as
Rhett and Link are making a ridiculous
video they like in fact this might be a
good video for us to make now that we're
just making videos that don't have to
tie into anything you know yeah
uh and it could be that
made this video where link acted like he
was Rhett who had uh woken up in links
in Link's body and then Rhett was like
on autopilot they didn't switch bodies
it's this weird scenario it's even
weirder than just Freaky Friday because
it's like half Freaky Friday yeah and
then it was like the day that this
happened and what went down is that
freaky Tuesday and then well yeah I mean
whatever day we decided to do it on and
but if this was happening in real life I
would be thinking of all the things that
I could do in a 24-hour period test
prove to the audience that it wasn't a
joke that I was actually inside your
body
so right what would be things that would
prove that it was me inside your body I
mean
would you try to prove that to Jesse
because
I can tell you I can tell you that she
would be very happy with that
uh well okay now I said that I was just
a joke I wasn't thinking about it was
just your wife when I woke up that's not
what I was doing well no you're not
don't bring my wife into it
um it was it was an innocent joke I kind
of in some sense this this is like a
little bit of Truth those um those uh
those scenarios where you wake up
and you realize you're an aunt
and you think if I was an aunt I thought
the this is the thoughtful guy lyrics
from back in the day yeah but we didn't
come up with a scenario this is a common
thought experiment
um
if you were an aunt what would you do in
order to get people to know that you
were an aunt and is it even worth it you
know what I mean right because in the
end it's you're still just yeah just
just make comedy out of it and be done
with it and so I think it's it would be
like hey we would forever we would
forever be committed to what people were
interpreting as a bit which is they made
a video one time where Rhett woke up
inside Link's body Rhett was on
autopilot we don't link was asleep
somewhere in the side Link's brain and
they made this video for a day and ever
since then they have maniacally
maintained consisted
the fact that that's exactly what
happened and it wasn't a joke
so maybe we should do that anyway
that's kind of what I'm realizing
all right because that is what I would
do okay
let's do it
creating content so where we write
uh yeah that's that's what I thought no
no
I mean no I think that you I was not
right you did not properly I didn't
think about content and anticipate I
didn't think about content uh speaking
of content before we get to the next one
uh you're you're making content
regularly with your dad on a podcast
called dispatches from Myrtle Beach it's
my dad's podcast I'm just I'm just along
for the ride right trying to trying to
ask clarifying questions and answer the
jokes that he
um
put forth to me
it's a it's a good time it's 30 minutes
every Tuesday and there's a YouTube
channel dispatches from Myrtle Beach so
you can watch us talk to each other
every Thursday please subscribe to
dispatchers from Myrtle Beach I think
it'll I think it'll give you a nice
little something to look forward to like
a the potential of snow
yeah it's like oh Link's talking to his
dad again what's his dad gonna say
what joke is Link's dad gonna tell from
the emails that he's gotten that he
doesn't understand the punch line
right and Link doesn't understand some
of them either well he has a son yeah
like father like son we have a good time
we connect I'm still learning stuff
about my dad
that's that's the beautiful thing about
it and there's a YouTube channel that's
what I said yeah watch it we can watch
it yep I said that youtube.com
dispatches from Myrtle Beach yeah
Myrtle has a y in it yep by the way it
doesn't it's not spelled like turtle and
if you want to email him you can do that
uh rather be shagging53 aol.com that's
his email address okay let's give me a
link scenario okay and so I'm starting
these off like we're gonna build to some
better greater things so we're starting
off these are like this one sucks is
that what you're saying no it's not that
it sucks it's just I feel like these
ones are more like one small variable
change okay that makes sense so this one
is what would link do if he was given
the power to be invisible for one day
okay
okay oh yeah I have to think about this
I have to formulate my own answer
huh
so you're saying nobody can see me
nobody at all can I pass through walls
well that would not be invisibility yeah
you can't pass through walls yep I can
bump into stuff still Yes okay you can
interact with the scene world you have
to be nude because that's how
invisibility works okay only your body's
invisible you can't even have glasses on
so take that into account
oh gosh I'll have a headache you got you
have contacts you could wear yeah but I
mean that they'll be floating in the air
yes but they are they're very hard to
see
I think that'd be about that's quite a
risk that's quite a risk
I think I have a really good answer for
this by the way I I don't know if I'm
going to be able to get as specific as I
want to but I I have an answer that when
I tell you the answer if it's not what
you're thinking you'll be like actually
that is a good idea
okay
I got my answer and I would go so far as
to say this is the correct answer for
anyone if you find out that you're going
to be invisible for a day okay
this is the answer that you should give
I think I have a really good plan okay
um if you're invisible for a day
I would hope
that you would use it to gain access to
and to something that you otherwise
could not gain access to right so stuff
in the area of playing pranks on people
or like scaring people I know people
like to think of that kind of stuff but
that's like low frequency thinking you
got to get past that I think I'm
thinking about it I don't know I I I
hope not
so I don't know you think I'm a
prankster uh you like to mess with
people you do like to mess with people
so that may have been the first place
your mind went but I will tell you that
for your sake I hope I did not formulate
an answer for entertainment a
formulating an answer
based on what I would actually personal
enjoyment yeah and not even enjoyment I
just answered the question sincerely
okay so I think that uh incor of course
it's got to be somewhere that you can
get in a day so it's going to be
somewhere in the Los Angeles area and I
think
because
I think you would select a interesting
person that you kind of want to know
more about like some some artist or
somebody that you're like into and you
would get into their house oh God
you think I would
you think I would Snoop around someone's
like Hollywood Hills mansion like I
don't know man like I've seen a lot of
pictures of Quincy Jones's house yeah
like from an architectural standpoint I
am very jealous of his house I think you
would want to go to a house where
something might happen that you would be
like man this one time I got invisible
and I snuck into
Frank Ocean's house and like you know
what I'm saying like yeah
he he is quite mysterious that's what I
think that you should do
in general I think gaining access to
something that you otherwise couldn't
gain access to and of course that you're
right about that you got to get in and
you got to get you're right about access
my answer hold on let me get look okay
let me let me think about a little bit
more so it's not about going to
somebody's house okay
uh there are a number of places it is
about gaining access to
something okay that otherwise I couldn't
get access to another good option would
be the zoo but
okay if you can be invisible at the zoo
that could be awesome so you can be in
the enclosure yeah because I believe I
know my religion dictates that I like to
connect with animals but no but think
about it I believe that you could pet
you could probably pet a lion and then
get away from it you think no you
couldn't you think you think a line is
not going to snap before it decides if
it can see what it is
it's called reflexes man it's a cat a
sleeping lion hey maybe don't go for the
Lions first maybe get in with like this
is not the end the bonobos you are not
on the right track okay so it's not the
zoo it's not it's not somebody's it's
not physical access I'll give you that
hint
it's not physical access that I can get
that I wouldn't otherwise get is not
physical in nature
well that's a strange thing to say
unless I'm just I'm completely missing
like you're you are a physical being and
you're invisible so going someplace that
you won't be seen yes is physical access
to gain
access
to what that's not a physical location
to gain access to like a like a
different way of being what do you what
do you mean do you want me to answer
yeah information
information okay
and
um I I decided to invest the limited
time I have in as an invisible
to learn
what people think about me really
like I wanna I wanna put myself in
positions where people give me an
example like every every relationship
that I have I'm talking work
relationships
friend relationships
I mean
it was a quick answer so don't I think
this is a good answer but I don't know
practically how you're going to
accomplish it I'm just going to start
I'm just gonna Shadow People what if you
pick the wrong person at all the time
they don't say anything
yeah I have to do some things to like I
have to plant things that make people I
think I got a good way to I can call
people on the phone when like you can
text people or call people I can be in a
meeting I can like
it you know how when the um the
principal of the school would like sit
in in the back of the room and the
teacher acted totally different well
what if the principal was invisible
that's the best way to give an
assessment of a teacher you'd have to do
something I'm going in a meeting to get
uh people talking about you so like make
like a
you know make a typical link request of
some kind of of someone I'm going to go
to the like the GMM writers room
and I'm gonna like just I'm gonna sit
right I'm gonna like just sit right
there in the corner but what are you
gonna and then I'm gonna start texting
people in the writer's room you can't
text somebody because your phone would
be floating you got to text before you
go into the room you got to find a
location that no one can see you and you
got to break your phone out and then you
got to text and then you gotta go then
you got to quickly get into the writer's
room so you got to find multiple
locations or else you'll just be a
floating phone
like
I would text Carney like I have this
idea of something I want to do on the
show and it would be like
just something dumb
and just something like bait people to
start talking trash about me and then uh
he would go into the room and I would be
in the room and say guys stop what
you're doing
I just got an uncharacteristic text from
link I don't know why he's texting me
but he has this idea and he wants me he
wants us to do it and what do you guys
think and I just want to see what what
they actually think about me
and then I feel like I know what Christy
thinks about me I don't feel like it
would be fair to spy on my wife
but I feel like you probably also can
predict I don't know what all these
people would yeah say about you without
you being there yeah maybe there's not
that much to learn and maybe it's only
maybe I don't want to learn it and then
this is just like reading comments you
know in one sense like you can find out
what people think about you real fast
yeah and after many years of that I've
chosen not to we've learned to not do
that so I guess I take it because I I'm
gonna learn my lesson I actually why am
I doing this I actually enjoy having a
self-image like a positive self-image
right not an other image yeah it's a
self-image yeah it's what you think of
yourself not what other people think of
you yes this kind of undoes everything
what about Frank Ocean's house yeah yeah
you're right you're right yeah yeah or
who I mean for who if I you know whose
house would you go to well and you could
be there for like an evening like a
Friday evening up there's a party I
guess the Kardashians I mean there's so
many of them really it's like fishing a
barrel I I want to have a high
concentration of people yeah but they
already have a reality show about them
that's true you know what I'm saying
they need to put me on a spot Jamie put
me on the spot who's super how come I'm
the one who's wrong and it's me and
you're the one who's right I'm trying to
help you with this who's super private
and would never let anyone Frank Ocean
is like a really good example yeah who
is like they're gonna do something weird
that you'll never forget and I don't
mean like you're sitting there in the
shower waiting for him to take a shower
I just mean like fly on the wall where
something interesting is happening I
mean if I would if I could get anywhere
at any moment I would go to like a
senate intelligence
you know meeting about UFOs because I
want to know exactly what they really
think and what they've really seen and
what they really know something like
that uh but I can't you know I can't get
to DC in that time and they got to be
meeting and they've got to be taught you
know it's not going to happen probably
you'd have to buy a ticket there's got
to be like an entertainment personality
most likely you'd have to buy a freaking
I mean you could try to sneak on the
plane but if it's fully booked you have
to buy a ticket then you have to wear
of clothing that covers every part of
your body like you gotta bandage your
face like the invisible Bandit I could
help you and then once you get off I'll
put you in my carry-on oh you're I help
you you're in on this yeah I thought you
were on autopilot yes that was the first
scenario so you can come to me and be
like hey I'm invisible I need to get to
DC
put me in your carry-on because I don't
think that's Fantastical I just I can't
I can't take this seriously this will
never happen okay let's try another one
okay
uh what would Rhett do if he can plant
one false memory into the minds of
everyone at mythical oh oh a false
memory into every employee yeah
okay I've got I've got one yeah I think
uh
I think it would be
the time and no one would be able to
forget it where
um
everyone was here everyone was back in
office every single like it's one of
those we have these meetings once a
month where like
well right now it's still kind of remote
people are still calling it from home
but let's say everybody came in for like
let's say it was a mythical party that's
that's the one thing we can get
everybody to show up for right okay the
freaking mythical party true so we're
throwing a mythical party
you remember when this happened this was
like a few Christmases ago everybody
remembers it
oh yeah yeah yeah and um uh we were at
this place and it caught on fire
and uh I know it's a bit morbid but
everyone was trapped no one could Escape
except you
um
you did you you there was a barricade
and then everybody had to get out and
then the only way that you could get
everybody out is by sacrificing one of
your fingers
and you open the door or whatever the
barricade was and you saved everyone's
life at mythical and then but I was
oblivious let's just say you you're
throwing me under the bus with this
memory and then I was the last one you
and like everyone's accounted for and
then you realize Where's link and
everybody's like where's the link and
then you run back into the burning
building and you
um
you rescue me
and your finger your severed finger
because I got to put it back on you got
to put it back on and perfectly by the
way yeah well it's under that right
under the Rings that's the severed spot
yeah
and so you're carrying me out
like
Backdraft Backdraft
and uh everybody's every it's seared in
everybody's memory oh literally yeah
that no matter what no matter how much
of an [__] that you are and I'm not
for the record but you could be now
because there's just no erasing
that and you're weeping okay you're
weeping
and you give this speech that's like
I would
I'd go back in that building for for for
any of y'all again right now
anybody want to go back in I'll go in
I'll get you back out
and then a few people tested you on
Stevie's like really and she runs back
in the building and there you are toting
her back out
this is quite you know you know what
this is exactly what I was thinking
even down to the Stevie running back in
uh you become you become the hero
and you're but the Weeping part is
important because it's like there's
you're not just a physical hero but
you're an emotional here's what you're
right about it was about doing and
planning a memory that would make them
think better
of me
but I currently do but not specifically
me but us so just so you know oh it was
so we could benefit from that okay thank
you and it was
I I need to work on the specifics
because if you if it's too crazy then
they might expect it to happen again but
I would want them to have a memory of
like
that month
when everything when everybody's working
on too many things and then
Rhett and Link came into the studio they
were like everyone is working so hard
and when we know that you're all making
the sacrifice and because of that we're
all going to the Bahamas for a month you
know what I'm saying like something that
created this this incredible memory and
I could I can put a bunch of different
memories it was like the mythical month
and the Bahamas and it was awesome I am
realizing as I say this now that it
makes it seem like it has to happen
again if things get crazy yeah yeah
I wish you could see my face
yeah but if that but if that was if that
if you believed that that it happened at
some point oh yeah awesome you'd be
you'd be like man they're they're great
they're they're great bosses now first
of all I do I think we are good bosses
and as many uh like fake rants as I have
have been released on the internet which
literally every single time we do this
at least 14 of the audience thinks that
it was legitimate and then another 14 of
the audience thinks that oh well this is
probably how he actually really is
um you can ask any a mythical employee
we have never yelled at any of our
employees under any circumstances no in
the uh decade or so that we've had a big
team but uh I probably have have I
yelled at somebody I I'm not I don't
really never happened the only person
I've ever yelled at
on the job right is that uh that guy on
the uh just being honest just be Just
Being Honest Tea the Wendy's shoot
yeah the only time I've ever yelled it I
don't yell at people he's what they call
a day player he wasn't English at all he
was a contract labor and he was not
doing what he was contracted to do
but his ass was hanging out I will tell
you that
yeah I mean should I tell that story
quickly
I mean sure so you should we were
working on that video the just being
honest and if you recall how that music
video works there is like a projected
environment behind us and the camera is
swish panning between these two
environments
um and the original plan was that there
would be some sort of Technology where
the camera
filming us in front of the because
basically the camera could move and then
the perspective that you see on the
background so this is like Mandalorian
type stuff would actually be in sync
with the camera so that it feels like a
much more immersive environment versus
just a rear projection environment like
we did on the right the textbook video
like the environment being projected on
the screen The Parallax would change
yeah the angles would change when the
when the camera would move filming us so
it would really be immersive and this
was a you know this was a big job this
was a corporate like Wendy's was paying
that was paying us to do this the Ad
Agency for Wendy's like major ad
agencies is actually going to be there
and they were scheduled to show up at a
certain time when we were getting ready
to actually shoot but of course we got
there really early we're setting things
up we're trying things out and this guy
who said that he could do this had been
a little bit wishy-washy in the in the
days leading up to it but he was like
yeah I can do it long story short is
hours and hours or two passed and he was
having technical difficulties and we
would check in with him or Stevie would
check in with him and he would say I'm
gonna I've got it I'm gonna do it it's
gonna be fine I'm gonna have it and
every single time we would check in yeah
another 15 minutes or whatever no no
another 15 minutes another 15 minutes
and this client is getting closer and
closer to get here and yes
the boiling point was Raising he was
bending over the whole time in four to
six inches of his ass crack or just
showing just hanging out the whole time
and that's not why I got mad at him okay
and I didn't even reference that in my
rant it didn't help but it was highly
unprofessional
he what he needed to tell us is that he
was not going to be able to do it so
that we could move on get things in in
place
and I just
snapped you know and and I don't think
it wasn't I I think the loudest I got
was
there's a group of people here and we
have been waiting blah blah like this
and I said and you keep telling us
you're gonna get this [__] thing to
work I don't I said I dropped the F-bomb
and that was you know it's like eight
nine years ago that guy didn't typically
I don't drop the F-bomb in public very
often at all but I I was like I need a
strategically placed
curse word to communicate This and like
after the rant like everybody was very
quiet he sort of like sheepishly I mean
ass was still hanging out but he
sheepishly just sort of like said okay
and then we moved he admitted that he
could not solve the problem he was not
going to solve the problem and we moved
on and that's why in the video it's just
real projection and me being fine me
over there on the side I was just like
and I've never done that and I don't and
I and I don't want to do that and that's
the only time where it felt like
broke
somebody's got to call you out on this
yeah I've never yelled at anybody
definitely not like that and I wouldn't
I wouldn't I thought it was hilarious I
wouldn't yell it into one of our actual
mythical people like that you know oh
yeah I would I would pull them aside but
he was just he was next level
[Music]
you have to bring shame into it
well okay if I had to do it again I
would have grabbed him by his underwear
pulled them up
and moved him into the hallway
so what what did we decide uh where do
we leave off on this one it was both
about making us look good uh you were
Backdraft situation I was Bahamas so but
to start with let's start with the B
yeah both start with b bag draft in
Bahamas give me another one okay
what would red do
oh this one's for for for Rhett for what
would like yeah yeah yes okay so what
would link do
if he had to filibuster in front of the
city council to delay them from making a
vote
filibuster you can filibuster a city
Castle yeah
yeah is there any
a government Council I think well maybe
not Spring Court but
yeah yeah okay good to know I think I
have
an idea I think
I have an idea
now a lot of people when
um when the filibuster they read a book
they'll read something and so I
immediately
knew that you would not do that yeah
okay
because you're not a reader
uh no but I'm pretty good at reading uh
out loud it's not original enough for
you okay like from all those years of
growing up in the church and like
everybody was caught on to read aloud
yeah yeah you're ready to read like you
had to get good at that you gotta read
in front of a group of people you got to
read in front of a group of people so
I'm I'm pretty good at reading aloud
but
I wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that
because I would I'm going to tell you
what you're going to do don't tell me
what you're gonna do oh yeah I keep
forgetting
I just wanna I just want to tell you man
speaking of speaking of comments I did
uh somebody was talking about something
that happened on The Mythical More the
other day and whenever I hear somebody
whenever I see somebody on Twitter or
whatever talking about something that
they
enjoyed from an episode I'll go to I'll
go to the episode and that's when I kind
of looked at the comments because I'm
like oh people are enjoying this I can
kind of participate
and it was something where people were
talking about how
often
you forget the rules to the game that
we're playing you don't forget what it
is that you're trying to do on the show
and how entertaining it is to people
and that is just happening right now I
just feel like it's just not worth it
it's not worth it to really know what's
happening
um yeah I I definitely agree as someone
who competes with you regularly on the
show they'll let you know the better
so you need to tell me what you think I
would do because I'm me and if I tell
you what I'm doing it kind of defeats
the purpose of this actually
interestingly so I will go ahead and say
that we are very much in sync right from
the beginning because before you said
the thing about the reading I was going
to say typically people read a book and
you wouldn't do that and that's exactly
what you said so right off the bat
perfectly in sync yeah this is where it
gets tricky
I think
that you would start
telling
stories okay and I think that you would
tell
you would start with Early Childhood
stories and you would tell stories about
like you'd be thinking like
oh I'm gonna I'll start with like Miss
is it Mrs Dean is she the one that took
care of you
um Loretta you got to go all the way
back okay you would go back to one of
those stories you know Mrs Dean was like
the orange poop guy right no that was
Loretta that was Loretta yeah
so you just start telling funny stories
like that and kind of embellishing them
and you would just sort of because you
would be like I have to have a plan to
kind of get through this day so I'm
going to go back to the beginning of my
life and I'm gonna start telling stories
and I'm gonna kind of just do these
extended overly detailed
sort of flashbacks throughout my life
until you know
it's time for everybody to go home lunch
time I think that's what you would do
because I don't think you would just do
impromptu off the top of your head
storytelling because that's very
intensive and like it's hard it's harder
to do that it's harder to do that for an
extended period of time when you're
calling on you gotta access the raw
material of your life it's easier and
you kind of you would turn that into
entertainment people would be like first
of all this is very weird
right right and then there might be a
couple of times where you began to like
you got weird ideas because you were
getting bored with your own self of like
telling these stories and you would like
lead people in weird songs and like get
everybody to clap together and you do
things like that
that's what that's my answer
that's pretty good the part that you
write about is
um
I wouldn't read a book yes we already
established that
I would also and you didn't say this but
I think it's implied that I would just
start talking and then people would
assume that I I that I'm saying
something pertinent like what is this
guy getting at
um because some people start their like
case in front of a school board or
whatever with an anecdote you know
when I was four years old and you I said
oh okay I did not think about it that
way
um
you know if
honestly if I'd had a lot maybe this
weighs better maybe I should do it this
way maybe once again you're changing my
mind okay well let's see what you really
would have done though well
I I just had to pull from what I've done
in the past so I went back to you know
rehearsal dinner my wedding rehearsal
dinner
you know the story's been told where I
just I decided to single out each person
who was attending my wedding rehearsal
dinner and tell them how much I
appreciate them individually
um starting with people that I didn't
know that well
right including people that
I didn't know at all because once I got
started I felt like I had to acknowledge
everyone in the room
but you're kind of starting with the
city council that you probably don't
know I've done some research though I've
got a dossier
I've got it's got a picture it's got
their name and it's got a little
something about them and so yeah I'm
going totally
freewheeling on this thing but I'm
making personal connections with each
person on this Council okay and decide
just wherever it goes so yeah I might go
back to a story of when I'm when I'm a
little kid but it's but it's it's
directed at this person
and then it's directed at the next
person like it's there's nowhere to
escape
you know yeah that would be
uncomfortable I'm talking to you
balding sir name
um that would be very uncomfortable Jim
Schmidt Jim schmidbits you have three
children
ranging in ages from three
to seven well I feel sorry for you
that's that's
a tough you know I remember I have three
kids too there you go make a person uh
you know when they were that age
it was difficult it was difficult there
were still diapers around there was you
know it's uh at that you know once you
have three they outnumber you unless yes
uh you're still married you're still
married so yeah they still outnumber you
if you're divorced if you're a single
dad
it's even worse this is what I would be
doing right okay so and I but I would do
it this was riskier this is a riskier I
think people would like me people
wouldn't want to stop me because it
would I would be making some sort of
thing about me
right if you made it he's gonna get to
me yeah but I mean where your little
example that you just gave right there
might make schmidbits feel uncomfortable
because I've done the research yeah well
I'm just saying like it didn't you
didn't say it kind of stalked him yeah
yeah I don't know
it's gonna feel weird it's like um I
spent a lot of time in your house you
did not see me
but if you look closely yeah you have a
tendency my contacts you mix our uh
we're visible
okay so that's what I would have done
and well you know what if I would have
really thought it through I'd have done
what you told me to do but here's the
thing we uh this is the most in sync
we've been because yeah that's pretty
close we knew that we wouldn't that's
pretty close that's pretty close good
one awesome okay so this next one
what would Rhett do if he was given the
task to travel back in time and alter a
moment in history oh gosh this is this
is so there's so much history
how can I how could I predict this
so re-ask the question
what would Rhett do if he was given the
task to travel back in time and alter a
moment in history
now you can't observe it you have to
alter it
you have to change the course of history
you taking that into account
huh I'm talking to you I know but I
can't answer that question without
giving I just want you to answer it I
just need you to acknowledge that
you're gonna alter
the course of history
I we did an episode of your biscuits
during the pandemic where we talked
about if we could go back to any one
point in time and just experience it
just be a witness to it
and not change anything
to me that's different but I feel like
maybe your brain went back to that place
I can't remember what your answers were
I remember that Jesus the whole Jesus
thing wasn't the main answer but that
you acknowledge that so that's the first
place I'm going is that like
you would go back and you would save
Jesus's life
that which seems like the great a really
good thing to do but that would really
screw up that might that screw up a lot
of history
everybody could change everything my it
might well not it would change a lot
I don't think you would do that
honestly you want to know the first
thing I thought yes I do is that you
would go back to the point where they're
deciding about like infrastructure like
they're building City infrastructure and
then they would um they would allow for
fiber internet all across the world
I don't know what even that I don't know
I don't even know how what that means
but I bet you Rhett was thinking about
having fiber internet everywhere on the
planet wow I can't believe you got it
that was the first thing that popped
into my head uh because I don't you know
neither one of us are like history Buffs
so I went in more of like an internet
technology Direction that's interesting
yeah but of course that's not about
fiber
I think you would go back to
um
I don't if you go to anything like
really primitive like
the
the invention of like controlling fire
it I need some sort of a hint give me
something okay
so the reason I couldn't answer your
first question which is like you have
you alternate you have to alter it
so
the way the question was raised was what
would you do if you were given the task
to go into changing an event to ultra
history
my first answer is refuse the task okay
so that's the first thing yeah you gotta
because I don't want to mess with
history don't want to mess with it it's
a trap Jamie has tried to trap you and
so then if this if if the second
if you know if you have to go back fiber
and then it is
so then what I would be saying is first
of all just by going back and observing
I am changing the course of history
right
I mean I don't really understand
quantum physics but it has something to
do with the observation actually impacts
the the results and so I act different
when people are watching me uh and I and
I'm in so I mean just showing up at any
particular place in history like even
the fact that my physical body would be
in in a place in like crush a blade of
grass
potentially could have some butterfly
effect that would alter the course of
history but if I were to go back I would
be thinking how do I have minimal impact
beyond my observation but I have to do
something to alter the course I would
say well my option me being here and
standing here is an altar in the course
of history so task accomplished so then
it becomes what thing am I going to
observe
which is to where you were just okay all
right
and I don't remember how I answered that
question before I do think I said
something about Jesus because
um that wasn't your main one though if I
remember yeah because it was something
about like I mean the reason I don't
think I would observe anything about
Jesus is because I don't think anything
I mean
personally my best guess
is that the probability that the things
that people think happen about Jesus
like as recorded in the Bible is what
actually happened is so low
that it's not like you're going to go
back and actually see him resurrect from
the dead like you're going to go back
and you're gonna be like oh yeah it was
this and we you know and his body was
thrown into a mass grave or what is
where did you go though
um
I've always been really interested
but I have two answers that are that are
equal right now one would be going back
to
something like the Great Pyramid
or maybe even more interesting
some of these like teaching each to like
some of these Pyramids in Mexico or
Central America
and just like seeing that Civilization
do their thing
to know if it was just
people just figuring stuff out or if
there was something else going on like
was there an alien directing this I
really got aliens on the brain today I
mean listen man just pay attention bro
and the other one
um
but I still doubt I I doubt that I'm
gonna see aliens I still think it's
gonna be like oh yeah oh that's how they
did it that's how they did it with this
big lever yeah we did that was part of
that discussion and then the other thing
is I'm really fascinated with like early
hominids you know other that's why I was
thinking about the like controlling fire
I thought you would go back yeah see I
was on the our ancestors and the people
who didn't win you know the people who
didn't get to be on the planet right now
like all the humanoid like people who
would be really freaky to interact with
like I'd love to just like observe
a group of those and I what I would want
to do is see the most advanced version
of a non
you know Sapient humanoid
they but they couldn't see you
I'm Not Invisible bro I know you would
have to make it you'd have to hide
yeah yeah because I'd freak every I'd
freak them out yeah
so that's what I would do and but be
like there'll be like carvings of you on
the Rocks but a very close second to all
that is fiber internet everywhere now
just put it just back at whatever point
when they were making a decision about
like the infrastructure I just think
underground actually you know
underground utilities like no
neighborhood is going to have telephone
poles it's like no no no no no no no no
everything's underground always
underground just take a trench dig a big
hole dig a trench guys no no no no no no
polls dig a trench we always dig
trenches fill it up later that's where
it all goes we'll fill it up later we
only dig trenches see
and there's lots of fiber in there all
right we're getting better at this yes
yes okay I think we have enough time big
questions these are Big questions I
thought it'd be fun you guys are
creative you know
um
what would speaking of aliens what would
link do if he found an ET like alien in
his backyard one day
in my tool shed
E.T like
so ugly but cute like a hairless cat
alien yes but cute
yes
I have a pretty quick answer to this
um
just instinctively strangle it to death
immediately don't give your answer
give me my answer
sorry how does this work
you just so so what you can do and I
think when you but the problem is you're
saying the funny thing is I I think I
have my answer you know that's what I'm
supposed to be saying I think I have
Maya here's the thing what we're
learning about you is that you have a
really difficult time thinking something
and not saying it which we already knew
about you but it's funny to see it in
action because the exercise you're being
asked to do is to think about something
but keep it to yourself you can't do it
no but you triggered me when you were
like I can't do that you were like I
think I have my answers like okay that's
what I was waiting for to say my answer
that's that part I know that's how one
part of this works so you consider the
scenario you think of the idea that was
kind of a joke anyway yeah my answer
can't be strangled you know I'm saying
that's just something that was the first
thing I thought that is not my answer
it's not what I would have acted on
that's not my answer so let me come up
with what the second thing I would have
thought that I would have actually done
sorry sorry E.T and I I think I've got a
good idea
in
he should have been smarter
if he had more information
I mean he didn't reveal anything to
humanity did he
in the movie oh no he didn't reveal much
that I can remember
okay there's an alien in my backyard
looks like E.T I'm gonna think about
what I would do but I'm not going to
tell you
yeah
okay
first of all
it's interesting that you said
he wasn't smart right like he well he
the way the E.T behaved was very smart
right which actually I think makes the
whole uh scenario that's portrayed in
E.T
so highly unlikely right because if a
being is smart enough to travel
intergalactically
they're going to be way smarter than E.T
was you know well we sent a dog into
space
so yeah so the only possible scenario
where by which you would experience what
we see in ET is if a greater
intelligence had sent one of their lower
life forms on a trip as a test which I
don't know the back story behind E.T but
that makes a lot more sense than him
being like the intelligent species who
came up with the travel mechanism to get
to Earth yeah he was just put on that
thing he is like the dog sent into space
or the rhesus monkey sent into space
but my general answer
and then we can get into specifics is
that you would basically do something
similar to what happened in the movie
which item in my closet which is
kind of behave like a child
no no okay so what I mean by that is
protect him from the government yes some
people might be like okay
this alien is in my backyard I need to
immediately contact the relevant
authorities because whatever this means
for our species in our civilization is
greater than me just having a buddy in a
closet but I don't think you would think
like that
I think you would think like Elliot
and I think you would make him an
additional
pet in your long parade of pets that you
already have I'd expand my religion to
include aliens yes in a pet way uh and
you would put him in that room that
Britain slept in when he lived with you
kind of a small not really a bedroom
yeah
and it would be the aliens room
and so we're talking about Alf now yeah
you would basically Alpha face him and
it would be the kind of thing where
you really I mean you would give him a
great life and you would also take
advantage of the entertainment
opportunities that this created for how
interesting it would be to come to your
home now for parties and you want to see
something maybe you would incorporating
them into your DJ bit
you want to see something
huh yeah yeah I come back here you would
do that you want to see something you
want to see something versus you got a
quarter I've got to get this thing to
the to the government I would only show
it to the kids of the friends that came
over
hey little
[Laughter]
Hey kid of my friend
you wanna come see something give me a
quarter yeah actually I'll show you this
E.T in my closet oh gosh it is so what
so what would you do for real
well you kind of threw me off when you
were like I knew that I knew immediately
what you would do
and I guess that's what you were
thinking I'm saying that you would not
report him to the authorities is what I
was saying am I right about that right I
wouldn't do that I would uh uh first
thing I would do is I'd call you yeah oh
yeah I wouldn't even show it to Christy
oh well thank you first right I'd be
like
what are this is now our problem right
yeah whatever we gonna do yeah yeah I
mean I kind of have some thoughts he
could live here I could charge kids a
quarter to look at him yeah that's kind
of the best thing I got yeah yeah and
and the scenario that I just kind of
laid out you hadn't called me yet
um
the evolution of how we've answered
these questions is I think we both just
tried to predict what the other person
would do hold on is it that was the
point from the beginning yeah
is that a joke or is that how your brain
works no what I was trying to say was I
ended up trying to I thought that's what
you were gonna say so then I tried to
say what you were going to say okay
which is call you because you've learned
over the course of this thing that like
after I've heard your answer I've been
like oh your answer is better than my
answer so what I've learned yeah yeah
yeah I learned my lesson I'm just gonna
call you okay yeah I'm just gonna call
you about this stuff there may be a few
other people I'll call I would get some
sort of consensus yeah I'd probably
invite a few people from the city
council that I connected with right
right right right you know and uh Frank
Ocean
uh I was in your house earlier what if
Frank can come on you would tell him
something that only he knows about
himself right he could come on over and
tell me what he thinks and then it would
be like uh there I would take a vote I
actually do think it would be more
personally fulfilling
um and I think that if we were to to you
had a meeting in the minds we may
actually come to the conclusion that we
weren't going to give him up to the
authorities I I I'm saying my
instinctive thing is like listen I don't
want to do this to you but I'm just
thinking about
things on a macro level here and we've
got to
figure out what this means for all of us
but
you know that's not as fun it's just
thinking what does this mean for us
right right I just don't yeah that that
is the first thing I thought was I'm not
just going to turn I'm just not going to
turn it over
but the thing is is the moment that if
we just said okay if we immediately turn
this into content uh it's like okay
let's document this whole thing and this
turn it into some sort of art piece
no one would appreciate that first of
all everyone would think it was fake
second of all people would be like why
did you guys selfishly right take this
for yourself and turn it into content
you know why didn't you tell somebody
about it I guess that's what makes it
such a good movie is that like
it's a kid making these choices it only
works if it's a kid there's this
emotional connection to this like
ugly but cute thing yeah and the
government is really represented in in
that movie in this like
really impersonal way you've got the
people in the suit you can't really see
their faces and you know it's it's it
helps it it's very much like a threat
to his safety
do we have it's actually a great movie
the more I think about it do we have one
more do we have a lightning I haven't
watched in a long time we have one more
okay
what would Rhett do
if he was at Jurassic Park
and he had to cause a distraction to get
past a velociraptor so everyone else
could Escape
oh he's being a hero again
[Music]
Backdraft
uh so I gotta create a distraction see
right now I'm thinking but I'm not going
to tell you what right you know don't
you should be trying to figure out what
I'm gonna do though
distraction for a velociraptor
they're smart
at least in the movie they were smart
create a distraction
so that everyone could Escape
and that doesn't mean that you have to
sacrifice yourself
okay
I think you would get in that jeep
and you would I mean
you would just be doing donuts
Jurassic Jeep Donuts
simple
you got to have a means to get away
I did not consider the Jeep
okay if there is a vehicle there what
did you do I'm gonna get in the vehicle
so you're right about that
I was just kind of picturing
sort of like a maybe just because it's
I'm thinking about Jurassic world but
I'm thinking did you do the bear thing
where you take the shirt off and you put
it
you still keep it on your arms so you
come up big and you you know
so I'm gonna say something really
Sinister and dark okay just fair warning
all right great because my first I
strangled ET a few minutes ago
because my first instinct was to
sacrifice myself right I mean to be
honest with you be like at least a
finger I'm gonna run at this thing and
I'm going to let it just go to town on
me I'm a big person it takes a while to
eat me whatever you know and so I think
as this thing is devouring me a lot it's
like a grizzly bear from starting with
the bowels
um I'm just waiting for people to escape
but on second thought that's not what I
would do
so
in this scenario I assume that I I don't
think if that was your first thought
that you'll have a second thought
um what do you do
let's just say that I have I know a
thing or two about the people who are
there right because Jurassic Park is not
like Disneyland it isn't the kind of
thing where
there's thousands of guests a day like
the group of people that you're with you
probably know them or you've gotten to
know them I think it was on the
Galapagos Islands is where it was
background checks all of that where was
it supposed to be Galapagos uh
I think it's a made up it's a made-up
place but it's like it's a remote island
you were probably on a boat with people
um I would find my least favorite person
from the group of people that I traveled
there with
grab them and chunk them no I mean
listen I wouldn't I would never admit
this publicly but I'm just telling you
what I would do and I would be like
Richard come with me let's just say his
name's Richard
and so
I'd get Richard and I'd be like we got
to create a distraction that's what I
would tell him yeah he'd be on team
distraction you need to be a little in
front of me and then
I would suggest something in the Moment
Like make yourself really big and let's
listen we've got to sacrifice ourselves
for the group for the safety of the
group make yourself really big and let's
both run at this thing and then and then
at the last second I would stop and let
Richard run right into him he came back
and then watch Richard didn't make it
exactly exactly Hey listen Richard would
go down in history I'd be like Richard
sacrificed himself we were but like we
were trying to figure something out and
Richard came up with this plan let's
just run at it and I was like okay and
he just ran faster than me you know and
and then once the thing just started
biting Richard you know limb by limb
that was when I left and here I am and
boy wasn't he annoying that was crazy
and everybody secretly be thinking
that's awesome about Richard but boy was
he an [__]
so gee whiz man I've given somebody a
story that really undid your background
I've given somebody like an incredible
memory like this guy lived his life as
an [__] no one liked him but his
final thing yeah but he did seven kids
to Jurassic Park well yeah and they can
forever remember dad
gave his life for us
oh gosh that's what I do all right it's
hard to anticipate that might have been
my answer but it is you're back to
you're back you're back to Net Zero in
terms of like your personal right you're
just being honest and vulnerable man I
know and it's now you're at Net Zero no
one thinks highly or lowly about it
Richard to sacrifice and stuff and also
over time I would lie to myself and
convince myself that what I said was
exactly what had happened it could be
actually really easy it can be done it
can be done yeah
um okay let's let's shut this down well
give me give me a wreck oh I've got a
great wreck
and of course you can let us know uh
your thoughts about this using hashtag
your biscuits you can call us and leave
a voicemail with any analysis you have
about this episode we'll play it at the
end of another episode 1888
earpod one
we know over the uh
New Year Jesse and I went to Mexico and
I've been to like the Yucatan Peninsula
before but Yucatan
I did not understand I guess maybe I
missed this the first time
but there is a particular preparation of
hot sauce that they do with
essentially burnt habanero peppers
so it's like a black salsa
and we went to a restaurant and they had
this
they gave they like brought like three
sauces
and one of them was this dark black
thing okay and I tasted I was like this
is incredible I like really Smoky things
and I like spicy things and this was
just wonderful combination of flavors
and then throughout our trip at other
restaurants and then at the place we
were staying I kept seeing like this was
a thing that was always was available
and I think it's like it's like a
regional hot sauce preparation that's
just black hot sauce
and so I just kept thinking to myself I
gotta figure out how to get this stuff
and of course all the places that I was
having it was just like homemade but I
found a brand on Amazon El Yucateco
that's a Mexican company that has a
number of sauces but this is their Black
Label Reserve chili Habanero hot sauce
and now this is not for everybody it is
spicy and it's it's not a safe
Normie hot sauce just so you understand
that right this is like if you want some
a little bit different if you want to
taste spicy soot
yeah get this is what it is if you like
to challenge your palette and that's how
you find enjoyment in it and which is
one of the ways that I'd like to this is
this stuff is incredible it's not as
good as if you make it yourself which I
would like to figure out how to make it
myself but you bought this and you vouch
for it yeah yeah it's very good fifteen
dollars yeah that's three no for three
of them that's a three count okay uh El
Yucateco Black Label Reserve chili
Habanero hot sauce well there you have
it
all right we'll talk at you next week
thanks for hanging out with us and our
predictions
hey guys my name is Mia I'm like halfway
through the weird job episode right now
and I had to tell you about this friend
of mine in college who his summer job
was water slide inspector so he would
like harness up and repel down water
slides to like inspect their joints and
stuff to make sure that everything was
safe for the the people going down water
slide one of the best things I've ever
heard honestly I don't know what that
says about my life but I love that for
him so thanks guys
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]